right yeah so the the biggest drama that
they have about it is well you're going
to hear the special but he obviously he
he goes back to the concept of him
trying to get people trying to cancel
him for his trans jokes that's the theme
of it right yeah cancel culture and like
twitter yeah
the lgbtq community
and i think the way that it's portrayed
in a lot of these articles that i'm
reading so i
you know there's a lot of people new
york times a lot of these big
publications and these writers are
coming after them right and clearly the
people who are writing it they're a part
of these communities that they feel like
he is
what the [ __ ] is that let's see
him bro for what on a tv show
alligator ass
he's sick bro that's for real that's
right that's him performing a live
concert or is he just doing this on a
show he's doing a live concert and it's
kind of fire he's singing i mean you
can't knock his singing sing is actually
pretty good he's saying dumb [ __ ] and
he's a dumb ass yeah he is 5 4 three two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast we have stupid nick the ear oh
yeah dumb stupid yellow hat did you get
the hat the yellow store
good company third street athletics
barbell oh that's silent oh that's
silent mike yeah yeah yeah mike great
apparel love his stuff shout out to mike
good time i got to meet him on jk news
such a good guy love that guy he's the
best he's a really good guy unlike you
and he knew the golden state killer bro
he knew him yeah personally he like grew
up with that four
how old is silent mike he's 72
72 years old 72 years old got to be
patrick.t riley he knows no serial
killers i don't know any civics i don't
think so not yet [ __ ] loser you never
know somebody could veer off the path
and out of all your friends who do you
think could be the most likely to be a
serial killer besides david
like what
why would i be a serial killer
i don't know that's a good question i
never thought about it david blacks out
and he [ __ ] hates violence i can see
alex killing people alex who alex costa
yeah oh yeah i see him killing people
yeah he got a very cold demeanor
sometimes yeah sometimes it'll be like
are you killing people you got serial
killers would you ever kill somebody for
real yeah so somebody comes up to tiff
they go what's up
uh
salvadorian mommy
mommy
mexican but she's not she's salvadorian
whoa bring me some of that salvadorian
ass i would have killed the guy
i wouldn't kill the game i'd just be
like get the [ __ ] out of here and then
we walk away yeah that would be it
that'd be the extent that's the [ __ ] i
feel like the weakest thing i've ever
heard in my life because at the same
time it's like get the [ __ ] out of here
somebody slaps tiff upside her head if
someone lays
i'm breaking i'm breaking bot i'm gonna
do my best to break something on their
body that's an ass whipping but i still
cannot guarantee this we'll see what
happens when that time comes but i'm
gonna i'm gonna have to break something
on their body
the only time i think i would
like i would struggled with like i i
think i'm gonna kill somebody is if
somebody did something to maya for sure
oh that would be that would be that
would be that where like i'm gonna kill
this [ __ ] family loved ones
friends even
we throwing down we doing one of these
oh we're doing the well we're doing up
and we go oh yeah there it is yeah you
know i mean i love it this will didn't
watch the dave chappelle special yeah i
didn't watch it out of all the things
you couldn't see you didn't watch the
dave chappelle special i just it's been
crazy back to back to back we just we
just got back we just got like you guys
we just got back from hawaii and then
hawaii which is one of the best places
on earth hey yo shout out to gilbert for
knowing the worst restaurants ever on
the island we need gilbert here to
defend himself no he has nothing to
defend we're not going to name names of
the places that he recommends just for
fun though
oh for sure gilbert can come in so i
could just make fun of this fat [ __ ]
how can you be that fat and had bad
taste buds they were trash the places oh
what was wrong with them el terribly as
a spanish scenario okay we already know
one of them that we talked about what
was the other one that he recommended
that was basura oh i can't see the boys
because i ain't trying to destroy what
type of restaurant was it it was an
asian restaurant of some sorts what kind
hop on this
no it was it was laotian vietnamese thai
whoa that's a lot faro you just made
that up no way you should have enemies
thai combo it was not good none of the
stuff he recommended was good i don't
understand when i meet somebody i know
who is a large large man he recommended
that to you
i thought you went because he
recommended it to you
yeah and i told you not to go and you
still went idiot well we just was it
trash
it was trash it was honestly the worst
restaurant we went to
out of the whole did you text what did
you text gilbert afterwards i was with
him and we were all like i paid 36
dollars for this and what'd he say
no we were all together and he was like
yeah it wasn't good like we all agreed
and the service was kind of shitty like
the guy that was there serving us and
look bro i'm very gracious when it comes
to servers because i used to be a server
i get it but this dude was like come on
bro do the bare minimum dog like it
looks like you want to spit in my face
for you being here dude if you're a
[ __ ] chunky dude and you don't know
good food why do why are you even fat
yeah that's true just get skinny dude
yeah what's the point what is the point
i don't get it yeah gilbert wakes up and
he's just like i'm just gonna shove bad
food in my face all day yeah [ __ ]
losers what an idiot or or
or he's very uh
maybe he doesn't have bad taste maybe he
just will eat anything because he's very
accepting of food what about that you
ever thought about that david's so yeah
except vegetables
except water instead of soda yeah
you know you don't drink soda you don't
drink something like that he'd be drink
he'd be eating vegetables but i actually
have no idea what he eats i'm just so
shocked
so he recommended this very specific
spot he was like oh send us the [ __ ]
yelp page or whatever i was like cool
went to go check it out right when i
went into this part of town i knew the
food was gonna be bad because it's a
high tourist area yeah with uh away from
waikiki yeah and all my hawaiian people
know a bunch of howlays over there
this is not going to be good hey the
howie's over there would be [ __ ] wild
i was at the airport and it was like the
uh departing away from hawaii daniel
anyway how do you say the last name in
in the only way and all your way no
continue
anyways we're at the [ __ ] airport and
this [ __ ] fat ass little white bald
white dude was over there and he's
talking to the lady that works at like
the tour shop with the like where you
get like sodas magazines what are the
[ __ ] and he goes so you're telling me
you guys have nicotine patches but not
nicotine gum
oh okay
all right
like he's giving her attitude like this
like i don't own the store but it's like
this ladies in charge of stocking the
store and also bro this isn't a [ __ ]
walmart you know you have a [ __ ]
nicotine addiction go to the store and
go buy nicotine gum before you go to the
[ __ ] store bro he's having
withdrawals yeah
like the way he said he the way he was
talking to this [ __ ] girl was like
and she just looked at him like
what do you want me to say yeah what do
you want me to do what we have is what
we have bro i don't order this [ __ ] yeah
and the way he was saying it was so
[ __ ] entitled i wanted to [ __ ]
slap him up as [ __ ] don't you empathize
with him because he's going through a
drug addiction problem he's going
through the troubles hey bro go to cvs
go to long stretch
did you ever think about that nicholas
dunham i got some nicotine form right
here dude it ain't much i'll tell you
that it ain't much it's impossible i
think it could last
two to three minutes
yeah that's good and that's all i'll say
all right yeah i said it dude you did
say it i told you
white man yeah and you're racist
you're a highly racist stupid son of a
[ __ ] but it is crazy to see how some
hawaiian like some of the locals they do
be like treating some of the white
people like super spicy and then to me
they were like hey bro like what can i
get for you they're cool what number are
you yeah let me let me get your food for
you and i was like this is tight
this is tight it is the best it's it's i
don't know if it's the best place on
earth but it's [ __ ] close dude yeah
pretty close to it
it's close the nature the [ __ ] people
there everyone at the airport so nice i
was walking by the security guard old
asian man
he looked at me i don't know why he just
went
and i was like
i don't know that it made me feel so
special and this one lady was like i
like your mask and i was like thank you
just well what kind of mess you wow it
was a kn94 but it was like pink so maybe
that's nice but she was very sweet
everyone's so nice everybody feels like
all the older people there feel like my
grandma yeah you know that's like trader
joe's that's what trader joe's feels
like
like the lego movie in there but
sometimes they're a little too happy and
i don't like it yeah it's like too much
we all happy i like it when it's genuine
i don't want it to be in your face i
don't want it to be like sometimes you
could tell it's like this is fabricated
yeah but if you if you're just genuinely
like hey what's up yeah how you doing
you have a good day
yeah you know that's awesome i like the
old guy giving you the that that's
that's that was out of nowhere
you and i was like it was your dad you
idiot that was my dad that was your
father
he was like i'm very proud of you bam
and he gave you the thumbs up and you
went [ __ ] weirdo and you just walked
off
and the spirit just floated away whoa
disintegrated
so because you're a decent human being
what did you think of the chappelle
special uh dude i love i loved it i
loved it
[ __ ] up charlatan honestly
honestly
anything chappelle does is the [ __ ]
obviously right but like he just
he it was [ __ ] amazing like all
around like amazing as [ __ ] the jokes
were good his storytelling was really
good uh the story he told in the end
about uh so the theme throughout it
which is why he's catching a lot of heat
is basically i mean he's he cracks jokes
about the trans community like he does
in all the other specials so anytime you
mention them and and not flattering
light you're going to catch some heat
right
and he just goes for it he's swinging
hard as [ __ ] but he tells a story at the
end about or well i don't want to ruin
it for you but he has his story at the
end that's fantastic and he like really
wraps it up and it really
puts a ball on it and it like really
emphasizes the message he's trying to
convey the whole time and it's just like
dude this dude's a [ __ ] master and
also what's sick about it is like
chappelle is doing
what like the role of a comedian like
that's exactly what a comedian is
supposed to do yeah like i remember in
high school like we used to have to read
shakespeare i [ __ ] hated shakespeare
i didn't give a [ __ ] i don't understand
what's happening are people [ __ ] are
they dying what's going on i don't
understand that's all you want to see
inside i don't know what's happening
dude yeah yeah uh you [ __ ] or you
died dudes are like saying things i
thought they were at dinner next guy got
stabbed in the chest i didn't
over a girl the whole time i had no idea
romeo you know so uh
but the one thing i do remember from
high school from shakespeare was that
that there was a play i don't remember
what it was but the jester was always
considered the wise fool and he was the
only one that could tell the king the
truth like that was like like
shakespeare wrote that in and like that
was his role he was called the wise fool
and because he was funny he was the only
[ __ ] that could tell the king
the truth without getting his
decapitated and like chappelle is
literally that like like he's i mean
they're trying to decapitate him but
like he's just telling it calling it for
what it is like
like he's just he speaks on things
there's there should be nothing that
like if nothing is so sacred it can't be
talked about right and that's the thing
is he talks about it and he makes jokes
and he doesn't bend the knee and that's
why everyone's [ __ ] pissed yeah but
it's overall i think it's amazing i feel
like every special that comes out with
him everybody tries to cancel some
portion of it you know try to cancel him
about a bit that he does yeah but he has
stood his ground and it's like okay what
are you gonna do like the greats like
the greats do that [ __ ] like chappelle i
feel like burr is kind of like that too
where he's like
yeah
three people were mad the whole crowd
was laughing right like i killed it just
one person at home watching the [ __ ]
that gets mad and i feel like it's the
same kind of situation with the
chappelle stuff because if he wasn't so
[ __ ] great at what he does he
wouldn't be getting paid hundreds of
millions of dollars to do a comedy
special right yeah so the the biggest
drama that they have about it is well
you're going to hear the special but he
obviously he he goes back to the concept
of him trying to get people trying to
cancel him for his trans jokes that's
the theme of it right yeah cancel
culture and like twitter yeah
the lgbtq community and i think the way
that it's portrayed in a lot of these
articles that i'm reading so i
you know there's a lot of people new
york times a lot of these big
publications and these writers are
coming after them right and clearly the
people who are writing it they're a part
of these communities that they feel like
he is punching down right and that is
the theme that he talks about in a
stand-up they're saying that i am
continually punching down on this
community
so i guess like
you know comedy is supposed to make you
think and it's going to
offend people for sure right i think the
only thing that maybe that i i thought
about right because i don't want to be
dismissive about how people feel yeah
and and you know the thing about like r2
i always say this it's very subjective
and you can feel however you want but if
those people are offended they're
allowed to be [ __ ] offended yeah you
can't get mad at them for being [ __ ]
effect doesn't mean they're right though
yeah no there's no right or wrong
exactly my personal opinion like if
they're offended they didn't like it
they're 100 right we can't sit here and
tell these people that they can't feel
the way that they [ __ ] feel because
that would defeat the purpose of
stand-up and art it has to be subjective
it has to kind of kind of pull you apart
right so half the room is mortified half
the room is laughing and i think that's
what great art does right
but
i think the the thing that i kept
reading in these articles that maybe had
me a little confused was that these
people that were trying to take dave
chappelle down
i've read this in three different
articles i forgot which one they are but
i read it and i understood and i
understood how they felt one part that
bothered me in every single one of those
articles that they kept saying this dave
chappelle used to be great his stand-up
was amazing it used to be it used to
make me laugh he used to talk about real
things and now he just goes for low
hanging fruit and he does stuff that's
very offensive towards my community now
the problem with this that bothers me
the most right they started using all
these jokes right they're like oh but
how he used this joke against like
homeless people blah blah blah he he
related to him getting the
the uh the kovitz shot as in the thing
that homeless people get so he's going
low-hanging fruit against homeless
people now this is where i find people
to be a little morally selective he did
a very famous stand-up bit which they
were fans of right of him talking about
the homeless guy jacking off in the
subway this guy is mentally ill yeah
he's jacking off spraying come on
everybody
exactly so why is it that you find that
funny exactly but not this one right and
the reason why is this is what i feel
anyways you only find things funny if
they're not talking about something
that's important to you exactly we're
talking about that today on jk news yeah
about the same [ __ ] thing it's like
people want to get mad
about
something that's sensitive to them but
everything else is different it's fair
game yeah you know and it's like okay
but if you're going to be mad at
you should be mad at all stand-ups
exactly because i'll use this as a great
example right so we talk about a lot of
stand-up comics who talk about their
life uh
getting beat up or whatever what their
parents this is domestic abuse and
violence and you're over here dying
laughing that they got their ass beat by
their parents and these like hilarious
ass-whooping stories right you think
it's [ __ ] hilarious i think it's
hilarious too but why is it that you can
look at that and say oh domestic
violence is okay but don't talk about my
community here right right so like
so this is what i'm talking about like
where where does this morality meter go
constantly when it comes to comedy i
know that there are boundaries but if we
can't do that equally across the board
yeah i think there's an issue and a
problem here because now we're saying
it's only offensive because it hurts me
right yeah because all that stuff is
offensive
um so where did i guess if i were to ask
him it's like well why did you draw the
line here and not there and if the
answer is because i'm a part of that
community well then you're being a
little hypocritical at this point you
were cracking up when everybody else had
a problem with the others right i don't
know i feel a little 100 and also too
like that the rule like even the term
punching down like
there's no rules in comedy there's no
there's no like comedy has to punch up
or what like comedies just make
[ __ ] laugh you know point out
in your way whether it's storytelling
pointing out in congress surprise what
however you do it make [ __ ]
laugh and that can happen in any way
sure you can make fun of like for
example a homeless dude you could like
that would technically be punching down
but there is
punching down there
there's bits where like even like uh
like chris rock right like uh uh black
people verse like
you know i mean like that's technically
like i mean i don't know if that's
technically punching down but it's it's
it's
you can punch down like as long as it's
[ __ ] funny that's that's the rule in
comedy make [ __ ] laugh it's not
like a morally necessarily uh
like it's not i think it's not a space
to be morally like right the other issue
that i have too i think people are
really misconstruing the concept of what
a comedian is a comic's position in
their life isn't to be your hero yeah
like people keep saying that he used to
be my hero he never asked to be your
hero right he actually never asked to do
any of that he was just trying to be a
comedian and be a comic right the idea
that somebody has to live up to your
expectation because this is what you
wanted out of them is a little unfair
right i now i do agree that people who
have a certain level of
of influence should be careful with
their words i agree with that stuff too
but the the argument that oh he should
be better because he was my hero that's
the role that you put on the comics
aren't there to be your morality police
right they're not there for that they're
a comic you know which is one of the
biggest reasons why like i stopped doing
you know i did a lot of like social dust
justice stuff too but what happened was
that people forgot that i was a comic i
was making jokes too yeah and so they're
like well how can you say this if you
it's like look at the end of the day
this is jokes yeah because when we put
ourselves at this certain standard
people will only judge us for that they
go oh you're a social justice person you
should stick to all this other stuff
yeah i don't think dave chappelle ever
said he was any of that stuff right he
just does comedy with the with uh
tidbits of his version of his truth yeah
but what you take from it is what you
take from it right like to say that this
person should be a hero to the youth and
everybody else is what you wanted out of
him it's not what he said or any comic
as a matter of fact to put that on
someone is not very fair right at all
unless they unless they ask for it you
know what they're like i'm i'm the
stance of you know morality which you
know which you know i gave you know
simulation about that was like right you
can't
be the the beacon of hope for you know
men and all other stuff
you also wouldn't be a good comic if
that like being a comic like
if you took that that's like the
opposite of a comic's spirit yeah to be
like i am the speaking of truth and
justice like like the whole thing we
[ __ ] on ourselves like we're
self-deprecating like the whole thing is
like we're a little [ __ ] up and like
that little fucked-upness goes inwards
as well so if you're ever thinking
you're the [ __ ] something's wrong you
know yeah and it come in just from a
like a comedian the spirit of a
comedian's perspective yeah and you know
i use this example too where i talked
about shane gillis right when he did the
whole little podcast thing because
hosting i didn't think that [ __ ] was
funny i didn't think it was dope i never
said cancel shane gillis you know like i
still think he should be able to perform
comedy and he's funny you know and his
special on [ __ ] uh youtube killer
hillary
he's so [ __ ] natural and good at what
he does which makes sense why he got on
snl yeah you know so i think people can
[ __ ] up and and the idea too and this
has nothing to do with chappelle's thing
is that people never think people can
change nobody ever gives somebody a
chance like if you get if they [ __ ] up
they could change or you could say you
know what [ __ ] you and move on you have
the ability to buy his tickets watch his
shows whatever else yeah right which
it's free market and whatever happened
to that right it's just like if you
don't like something just don't watch it
yeah and also who are you to decide that
i can't watch this yeah you know and on
top of that too it's like it's we're all
hypocrites at the end of the day right
it's like
people i just don't like when people
like to shine the light on other people
saying like you did this you did this
and it's like what if we did the same
thing to you right because all these
people that want to go out and like make
a stand and like cancel everybody and
say like you're a piece of [ __ ] for
saying this i really want to be like
well what kind of [ __ ] skeletons do
you have in your closet right because if
you want to expose everybody else
i feel like in a weird way it's like i
feel like most people
don't go through their life trying to do
that trying to expose you you can feel
when someone's trying to be shitty and
you can feel when they're coming from a
good place exactly so so it's yeah it's
case-by-case situation like there was a
video of i saw it on a podcast i don't
remember i think it was your mom's house
but there's your mom's house [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude there's a gummy yeah he got
you so good there
there's a video of uh it's like a trans
lady in in a car at like a sonic or some
drive-through place oh that video was
crazy and she's like she's like
filming this
latino worker dude and she's like yeah
but why did your worker call me him like
so it's like it's like it's a guy who
transitioned to a girl trans woman right
so uh he's like yeah why would he call
me sir like what about me looks like a
syrup
the guy is also like the guy's just
trying to work yeah i was like i'm sorry
he's like sorry yeah you know i [ __ ]
up sorry give me some grace he was like
it gets down to the point where the the
[ __ ] gave the dude the card and
it says will smith on it or will jackson
or whatever the [ __ ] his name is the
person's name is will yeah and so the
guy is like well he read the name will
and assumed because you have a male name
baby girl is running around with the
name [ __ ] will you know like
my bad [ __ ] damn you can't you
can have some empathy for me a little
bit but this dude this dude's coming
like just trying to [ __ ] like just
basically trying to dominate this dude
to look good or feel good it's bullying
like that's just straight up bullying
and by the way nobody sympathizes with
this woman at all right at all and you
know why it's because
i actually when i first watched this
video i thought it was i very much
assumed that it was fake because i burst
out laughing it was so outlandish well
because she's where she turned
and see that what makes you think what
about me looks like
a man turns the camera five o'clock
shadow what the [ __ ] five o'clock shadow
with red lipstick
i'm like dude this is i was like this is
a prank for sure yeah
a [ __ ] couple days passed and it was
real right i was like oh this isn't a
prank this is for real yeah the
motherfucker's name was a was a a
cisgendered male name on the credit card
yeah yeah so what the [ __ ] here yeah i
mean that's just like come on now yeah
they assumed because you have a typical
male name on your credit card also too
you were three hours away from having a
full beard yeah so
you know
look at that like i said i addressed her
as a herd that's she's a she's a thank
you for clarifying they didn't do that
from now on
she's a she cool you've addressed it
they [ __ ] up let's move on let's move
on here he said look your name is
william shatner yeah i thought you were
a guy because of the name on the thing
well my bad whatever you
whatever your preferred pronoun is it
will be cool like it's over done let's
move on let me see i'm making like a
[ __ ] and let's move on
the burger now can you can i give you
your fries and get the [ __ ] out of here
like yeah apologies and that person was
probably trying to start some [ __ ] yeah
yeah and then recording and making the
whole scene out of it right if it i feel
like 99 other people in that same
situation were like oh it's all good
don't worry about it yeah i don't think
this person too represents like a
majority of fans
or something for sure you know like the
trans community so they're going to get
a lot of flack for people like that too
yeah because they try to put this
movement on their back and they're
making these people who you know who
have transitioned look like [ __ ] because
everybody now thinks that every trans
person is crazy like this person exactly
i'm sure there's trans people that are
are so angry about that they're just
stupid they're just like bro we just
want to live our lives figure our [ __ ]
out lay low and then they have all this
[ __ ] to deal with like what the [ __ ]
yeah this podcast is brought to you by
hello fresh my friends you guys know how
much i love hellofresh because i love
making bomb ass food and a lot of the
times you guys know that when you go out
and you go ahead and cook a recipe you
see online you always have extra
ingredients well this is where
hellofresh comes in it's super fun and
affordable because it's 30 cheaper than
grocery stores with pre-portioned
ingredients that ensures you won't spend
money on excess ingredients and food
while you save on your shopping trip no
more grocery stores no more excess
celery 36 pounds of it you just get what
you need and you end up with one of the
most delicious meals and it's home
cooked but it's super super easy and
delicious trust me all the stuff that i
made with hellofresh has been bomb asked
my fiance she loved every recipe and by
the way if you've heard me talk about
green chef well guess what hello fresh
and green chef my friends has an amazing
relationship together so you can enjoy
both brands at a discount with me no
worries so check it out my friends go to
hellofresh.com brain14 and use
codebrain14 up to 14 free meals
including free shipping once again go to
hellofresh.com brain14 and use code
brain14 hellofresh america's number one
meal kit
and i feel like that person's just not
really a normal person like that
person's kind of just an [ __ ] that
person's big kid 100 man woman whatever
you're a [ __ ] douchebag and that
doesn't represent the actual population
yeah because there was a part in like
chappelle's uh stand-up and you're gonna
see this little bit too you're gonna get
this little bit ruined because you
didn't watch it like a normal person
whatever but basically there was a part
where um chappelle does a show with with
daphne
and um they're they're having a good
banter back and forth on stage and he
goes i believe you and she snaps at him
she goes i don't need you to believe me
i just need you to treat me like a
person yeah and that was like something
that very profound that he was saying
it's like
what is this idea that we can't just
treat people like people yeah yeah like
just treat people like people that's all
that it is what i was thinking about
this today too it's like
even like i'm friends with
legitimately some pretty crazy people
yeah where i'm like this person's crazy
yeah but i still love them and i'm still
cool with them like i don't have to
agree with you on every single thing
exactly cool with you and it's like even
if like there's people that like you
know that you don't have to have
everyone accept
like everything you believe for you guys
to get along like it doesn't have to be
like that we could just be cool we could
just be people like you believe the
earth is flat and i don't but we still
like we could still be cool we could
have a good time you know what i mean
like it's not it's like there's people
out there that don't think that you're
like for example from a trans
perspective if someone was trans and
someone was like i don't really think
that's a legit thing that's i could see
where that's offensive but those two
people can still get along like you
don't have to believe me just [ __ ]
let's just be humans and just be cool
yeah treat me like a decent person and a
human being you don't have to believe
any of my [ __ ] yeah i believe it but
just treat me with respect yeah right
exactly that's most people what they
want just mutual respect mutual combat
and that's just mutual comment yeah yeah
mutual combat let's just duke it out
like men and women let's [ __ ] knock
each other's teeth out obviously like
even like they're sorry to cut you off
but there's like people that like still
don't think there should be interracial
couples you know there's that still
exists i agree dude it's like it's like
that he would never exist
my children would never be birthed but
like how would you know what i mean like
and if you spent every hour like [ __ ] i
gotta make everyone think that it's okay
it's like why would you want to live
like that yeah that's true it's like a
miserable experience because it's also
like you can't control what other people
think right you can't you can't control
what other people do so you have to kind
of live in your own space and then i
think the best way to deal with all this
stuff in general is just to be like okay
i disagree with you or you might be
[ __ ] batshit crazy and that's fine
people in your life people might even
disagree with this i personally don't
give a [ __ ] what you do in your private
life yeah don't bring that [ __ ] to me
don't bring it to work and don't bring
it around again i agree with that
you like okay so that's annoying like we
we always see this stuff where somebody
gets cancelled over like emails tweets
or whatever from years ago right
yeah yeah the john gruden thing right
which by the way
nobody's justifying what he's doing or
saying behind closed doors but my issue
is is if he brought that [ __ ] out onto
the field brought it around people and
he was saying this to other people yeah
you have no id if you guys have ever
played a sport in your life [ __ ] that f
word that ends with the agate at the end
is said profusely
so much [ __ ] you [ __ ] sports are
always has been like that so when they
hear these sports yeah all sports
live yeah xbox live yeah go kill
yourself go die i [ __ ] your mom in her
ass and it came out her belly button how
old are you three years old
three years old yeah why are you
watching
it's impressive yeah so it's you know
once again i'm not over here batting for
his morality like you know whatever he
said
is [ __ ] terrible or trash i think the
issue that i have is with people saying
like i can't believe somebody would say
this when you are that person exactly
that's see that's the hypocritical thing
it's like bro you're gonna get caught
too one day just wait just wait yes
everyone's gonna get theirs bro and for
you to stand on a [ __ ] soapbox and be
like uh you're a piece of it like just
to name call and just hit kick people
while they're down it's like you just
wait till you get yours bro that's hard
right and
[ __ ] some of us are trying to do the
best we can yeah but i've never done a
single thing wrong in my life
you assaulted a man outside the gym and
that was fully within my right as an
american but do you hate america what's
up al qaeda
what's up guys
i didn't know you were part of the
taliban yeah [ __ ] stealing funyuns
forever
yeah foreign
[ __ ] funyuns he gave him to me it was
tribute for protecting him but david
blacked out and forgot the part where he
had him by his neck yeah he's like give
me your [ __ ] help i've never slept
rum deep a single day in my life however
i once watched the kid get stomped out
and i did nothing and i'll tell you this
i actually kicked him once too just to
see how it felt oh he didn't then i
walked away oh and i felt so bad i cried
and i apologized to him but that was
that was see the fact that he apologized
to him you did your part he had a kid
you know what i want to kick him and see
how it felt i kicked this kid i felt
terrible and it's fine because you
apologize but you're still going to hell
but the fact that you still apologize is
great yeah that's nice you learn oh you
can't apologize and i've never done
anything wrong ever ever again that's
right i've never ever did anything wrong
it's impossible i dare you to dig into
don't dig into my tweets i dare you
i dare you
i remember yeah sorry i was gonna say in
the uh chappelle's last special uh there
was like an extra bit that like so he
does a special and then there was like
an extra like little thing that he did
uh whatever it was like a little extra
scenes or whatever but he has this
really good point like he he has people
asking him questions and they're talking
about daphne actually who's the
transgender lady that he meets or
whatever
and they're like talking at the bar and
i don't remember specifically exactly
what he used but there was there was a
uh article i think that was written or
something where he was making jokes
about a certain community and the
article was saying how like by him
making jokes about this it was like
actually including the community it was
like like like oh like because joking
with people can be a sign of like i love
you you know what i mean like that's
another thing that people don't
understand sometimes it's just a lot
it's a love language you just talk [ __ ]
but like you i really i talk [ __ ] to you
all the time but i love you you know
what i mean like [ __ ] you i hate that
exactly there you go hate it so so uh
you're gay
you just say you love me on a podcast
bro were you gay or something so
but and then he's talking to daphne and
then daphne was like yo i wonder why
they never say that about the train when
you're making trans jokes that you're
trying to do that with the trans you're
trying to normalize it like
yo yeah you know like working in a
conversation creating conversation
making like
humor is a a bridge it can be a bridge
you know and um
like i don't know the best people that
i've met in my life are people that can
take a joke about themselves 100 percent
like if i meet somebody and i i say
something and i i could tell they can't
take the joke i'm already like 80 i'm
like i'm not really gonna like this dude
yeah those rum deep jokes don't like
them at all
but like you know so like being able to
take a joke like that that's how you
build that's how we get the
uncomfortable [ __ ] that we can't really
talk about in necessarily a serious way
maybe we address those issues
you know it's a way to bond actually
yeah it's a way to talk about the [ __ ]
that's uncomfortable and you know he
also made a point too and i think a lot
of comics make a point too when when we
make these jokes right um and then once
again they have to be funny that's like
the that is the main requisite yeah it
has to be funny it has to be crafty you
know sure to do whatever for it to be
acceptable right i think that's the
first thing yeah
but afterwards if somebody walks away
and they go [ __ ] trans people he goes
you're a piece of [ __ ] of course [ __ ]
you and then we'll be there to back you
up when somebody takes these jokes and
they try to weaponize it again exactly
we'll be we'll be right there with you
standing up saying [ __ ] you like 100 you
know because we've seen comedy where
people are
trying to like make a stand about
something kind of and then the joke is
secondary but there ends up being no
joke and they make a stand up making a
statement and everybody knows it could
be the most like
uh
like just regular things that you can be
talking about nothing heavy nothing
crazy but because they talk about in a
certain way and if there's no joke and
it just seems like them just ranting and
there's no funniness to it it's like
weird yeah like you've been in a crowd
where someone is like trying out maybe
not trying out material but they're
doing material and it's just there's no
funniness but it just kind of sounds
mean and kind of like yeah what the [ __ ]
is this you know what it's like it's
like if somebody that doesn't know how
to play guitar starts going
he's trying to play music but it's like
he doesn't have the skill it's the same
thing with jokes it's like if i'm trying
to make a point but
there's something funny in here but i
just don't have the
skills too because
one of the biggest things that happened
was
one of the bigger things that happened
was netflix
the netflix trans employees and allies
said that they're going to leave netflix
sure because they're not going to bring
down the special and then obviously
netflix was like no we're going to leave
it up yeah which i thought was dope yeah
whether it was like comedy which you
know which i really do appreciate yeah
now the hard part for i think these
companies too is that they're going to
have to live and die by that standard so
because if they do that where somebody
puts out a special that everybody really
liked that they thought was funny but
it's a comic that doesn't have a bigger
name as uh chappelle and then they take
it down then they're gonna have to eat
those [ __ ] words because now they
just look like oh you're only doing it
because it's dave chappelle right so
they have to live by that standard now
sure because one of the biggest problems
that people have is that oh the only
reason why people find this acceptable
is because it's dave chappelle if it was
somebody else they would they would just
do it by the dollar signs and then take
them off but see that's why dave
chappelle so great is because he doesn't
have to he doesn't have to take this on
yeah but he is kind of paving the way
for he's he's making it like he is the
like you need a guy like him he's a
figurehead that's big enough to take it
on that that sets the momentum in the
other way where it's finally like enough
enough like okay you're upset sorry
you don't have to watch it but you don't
get to decide what everybody else gets
to watch there's a lot of people that
just [ __ ] like it whatever reason one
of the worst things that ever happened
and it's it's it's a true sign of people
kind of uh
just being a [ __ ] is when um the one
indian american comic went to the
did a stand-up show and he was making a
joke it was a race joke right and he
said the step set was going completely
fine and then he made that joke where he
said nobody i think this is i'm
butchering the joke but it's like nobody
chooses to be black and gay at the same
time because who had chose to be you
know be oppressed twice over yeah right
[ __ ] funny joke and then the premise
and then everybody was like started
booing him and they took him off the
stage saying that he was racist like
somebody screaming that he's a [ __ ]
racist when really the joke is not about
him being racist he's saying that it
sucks to be in a country where those two
minorities get bored
and marginalized that's the joke but
then he's also making a point that being
gay is not a choice exactly exactly yeah
exactly so that's the joke that he's
making but they just heard black they
heard gay and they're like you're
canceled get the [ __ ] off the stage and
i think it was at columbia university of
course i think i know who you're talking
about yeah he's [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
funny stan
i follow him on instagram i can't
remember his name right now but um i
remember that too because i wanted to
hear his set and i heard the joke and
i'm like that wasn't even racist he was
saying good things yeah people think if
you mention race like it's automatically
just racist it's like no it's not no
it's not
like race is a thing and especially if
you're not at that race right i feel
like you're more racist if you can't
talk about race exactly than if you're
just uncomfortable especially if you're
kind of especially if you're like
tiptoeing around yeah you know like if
if you don't feel comfortable like i've
met people where
certain white people or they're just
like when they're talking and they'll be
like and they're talking about black
people and they go yeah yeah and then
the black person like whisper and it's
like why'd you do that that's weird yeah
that's weird and you gotta call them out
and then they go oh no i didn't mean
anything by that oh yeah i've sucked a
lot of black dick i love it
it's correct
guilty white [ __ ] are the worst
and i get the worst part of it is like
them like tiptoeing around it but then
there's like a weird thing where it's
like
but it's like a subconscious thing right
it's because they they kind of think a
certain way about it and it's projected
in the way they say things like that
there's very like small
weird subconscious things that certain
people do where you could be like oh you
you're weird
very weird also i've always wanted like
where is all that guilt coming from yeah
why are you white guilt bro because you
guys own slaves but but it's but it's
also like how they talk to other people
the thing is is like you can you can be
white and be like yo there's problems we
should work on them together let's fix
this [ __ ] yeah and not feel guilty at
the same time like what where's the
guilty like i don't understand why like
when people are like it's like why do
you feel like i mean i understand you
could be like yo things are [ __ ] up we
should work on them together but like
when dudes are all weird it's like why
are like that's your weird racist
[ __ ] in you yeah in my opinion like
when i see it i'm like that dude's weird
and racist for sure yeah because like
the conversation they have
you were just like because look white
people were just born white the way
everyone was born what they were they
were born in a better circumstance for
sure like like i said especially in this
country
but the thing is like
you you did like even white people
didn't decide to be white right so it's
like cancel pat dude
bring it on
all of his privileged [ __ ] yeah he
got half whiteness up in here dude yeah
dude freaking vanilla frapper white oh
where he's like if i get to choose after
i die i get to choose what race i'm
going to be he's like i'll take white
please again yeah right i'm going to
re-up on that white it's too good he's
i'm sorry he's like no [ __ ] way i'm
going to take white again that's a very
funny [ __ ] joke you know and he's you
know but see like that's somebody when i
hear somebody say something like that
i'm like oh for sure that guy's not
racist because he's comfortable talking
about difficult things it's
the most obnoxious thing is when i look
on facebook or social media and
everything that a person posts has to do
with racial issues and everything else
and their profile is their token asian
friend token black friend token mexican
friend yeah he's like why is your
profile picture this this this ethnic
person that you're using as your [ __ ]
token i'm not race first of all they're
not your [ __ ] prop that [ __ ] is mad
racist dude
that's a projection it's like it's like
it's like why do you feel like you have
to put this out there yeah why don't you
have to put that on like you're cooling
people again
like they're badges bro i know i got
like a pokemon gym dude
electric type yeah
collecting people
you'll see the yeah
and then you'll see them all this social
justice [ __ ] yeah and in their profile
it's not just their because it's your
profile why is it that it's that ethnic
person that your asian best friend that
you met last year that's in every single
one of your profiles it makes you raise
an eyebrow it's like for sure okay we
get it you're not right you like asian
people cut that [ __ ] out dude yeah make
it just your regular profile that's what
i'm saying too it's like sometimes too i
feel um they people get [ __ ] on so hard
that they feel like they have to try so
hard not to look a certain way and it
does the opposite effect yeah you know
so and it goes back to that comment of
you don't have to maybe believe what i
say but you just have to treat me with
decency yeah and i think that's what
that's just what we have to treat people
like people no matter what race they are
whatever background they are just treat
people like people that's it because
when it gets weird is when some people
have a preconceived notion or judgment
of the person that they're meeting
whatever
race they are whatever socioeconomic
background they are and then they kind
of you could tell how they talk to that
person is like what they really feel
about that type of person or what they
think that person is and it's like that
weird kind of judgment and like
projection that they they put onto that
person in their conversation and some
people can see that subtleness and it's
like huh interesting weird this just the
try hard i really dislike like i hate
the fact that every time we talk about a
subject that has to do with like some
type of social issue there's these
phrases and terms that i never knew
existed like what like it'll be like oh
you know what like i'm not sure if uh
the poverty in l.a is going to be fixed
oh i didn't know you were uh a poverty
levelitis yeah like where did this where
did this phrase [ __ ] come from oh
yeah it's like oh you're anti-pro
politician of swannaski's yeah exactly
people just make up words why don't you
keep making up [ __ ] words and it's
like you look it up it was it was
created like two weeks ago it's like oh
so you use this [ __ ] term that makes
you feel like you're more superior than
me because i don't know what the [ __ ]
this means it was made up last month you
cut bag well that's kind of their tactic
because they just make up words yeah
kind of win arguments in a weird way you
know yeah you [ __ ] pro pro uh toe
[ __ ] itis [ __ ] like i don't know
what the [ __ ] it's just obnoxious it's
very obnoxious yeah because this is like
a weird games it's like a weird social
currency it's like it's it's it's like
their way of gamifying it right it's
like how do i
make this
i don't know what the word is but it's
like it's like there's a gross feeling
to it because whenever someone is trying
to like push a certain agenda they
always like kind of
it's like very up in front of your face
like you know what they're funny think a
certain type of way one of the things i
love watching and it's not because i
care about the topics that are being uh
talked about on these debates is when
some kind of political pundit will come
up and they'll
argue with a college student right and
they go up there to try to take down
this person right whether it be uh
what's his name the fast talking
ben shapiro it could be ben shapiro it
could be some other right-wing or
left-wing person and basically they go
up they give these speeches these
college speeches and then they allow
people to come up and debate with them
the reason why i like watching this not
because i agree with everything ben
shapiro says or if even if i'm listening
to the argument at all what the reason
why i enjoy watching it is because i
like watching people not know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about yeah right
right so if you're going to go up and
you're going to speak and you're going
to debate somebody you have to do it
civilly you have to have a conversation
objectivity like yeah and you have to
come ready and prepared but a lot of the
times what happens with people
especially specifically when they're
younger and i
probably am still like this now and i
was even more like that when i was
younger is that we come up and we say
all the stuff that's based on emotion
but we don't have anything to back it up
so when you come against somebody who's
very prepared and all you do is go well
this is how i feel
it's not going to work yeah and then you
try to talk over people you don't let
people speak it becomes very problematic
and that's what a lot of younger people
do because i was just like that if you
want to go ahead and have a discussion
with somebody conversation is the most
powerful thing that you could ever have
you may not agree with somebody but you
could walk away at least understanding
somebody a little bit better but people
don't want that they want you to either
look stupid they want to tear you down
right when you tear that person down you
feel like your dick just got a little
bit bigger but see that's that's the
problem with a lot of the like the
colleges right now like because it was
starting to happen when i was in uc
santa barbara i started noticing it i
didn't
like this that's when they started
pulling out trigger warnings and all
that [ __ ] i was like what the [ __ ] is
what the [ __ ] is a trigger warning like
what but like i know what these trigger
warnings are [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] but but a
lot of a lot of uh
schools or or um
majors will teach are trying to make
activists yeah right the whole point of
college is to make [ __ ] think
for themselves
are trying to make activists and when
you're younger you're you're more
emotional like you said so now you just
have a bunch of people that are just
spewing an ideology basically like a
religious fanatic and never be learning
how to think for themselves so that's a
that's a huge like we're going to see
how that [ __ ] unfolds in the
following 20 30 years what's the next
generation gonna be like it's a big
that's a big
problem there's always cycles of it too
you know like where people start to have
this mindset of like activism first but
then at the same time like what you were
saying
like the data or objectivity and
arguments they speak way louder than how
you feel about it because a lot of times
they don't really align with each other
because a lot of people when it comes to
like activism or
whatever they're saying a lot of it is
like half truths
it's like both things can be true about
a certain like any
uh
any issue that you take
yeah you could feel some type of way
about it but it's usually coming from
one side the real issues are always
not black and white there's so much
nuance that goes along with it and there
might be parts that you don't agree with
but are just reality yeah in a perfect
world we could solve all these issues
with yeah rainbow sunshine happiness but
in reality that's just not the real
world like the real world has a
completely different way of handling
things and you have to adjust your
approach and your solutions to figure
out what you're trying to fix with real
world problems and if you can't
account for that in your solution which
most people don't have when they have
issues so what you're saying is that
women like to be sexually assaulted
yes
but you saw that for example this is a
great example and the reason why i made
that joke was because there's that
famous clip
with jordan peterson and he was being
interviewed by uh
by
she was a famous like reporter or
something it was like in the uk but she
kept on doing this thing where she would
ask him a question and then put words
into his mouth yeah so she'll ask him a
question and then she got wrecked in the
comments because of how unprofessional
she was and this is an adult and this is
somebody who's highly intelligent she's
strong whatever whatnot and
i forgot what the topics were per se and
once again i'm not really listening to
the subject matter at hand i'm just
watching how people have debate tactics
and he'll write no what i believe is
this is this and these are the numbers
of statistics so so you believe that
women are inferior he goes that's not
what i said at all what i'm saying is
this is it so you believe that women
should just be be subordinate to men he
goes
no
smiley goes no no that's what i'm saying
is this this and that so what you're
saying is and that was a joke is so what
fill in the blank yeah and that's how a
lot of people
that's a bad journalist right a good
journalist if they're trying to prove a
point and get you with something right
if they if they know what you're saying
is [ __ ] they'll just ask very
leading questions
and and those questions alone can
dismantle someone's argument
for if you if i think you're wrong if i
really think you're jordan peterson and
you think that women like to be sexually
assaulted i could give you this perfect
questions that'll stump you and you
won't be able to answer and by you
speaking
and answering these questions you're
going to make a fool out of yourself
like i feel like that's good journalism
you know
like for instance like the prince henry
stuff like prince uh prince charles the
guy that [ __ ] uh
the molester dude yeah melissa like that
the person the interviewer did such a
good job of asking leading questions and
he made a fool of himself sure you know
what i mean but if that to me that's a
good journalist because they can ask the
right questions and stump you just by
asking the right questions and you look
like a [ __ ] fool because you don't
have those answers and the way you
answer those questions
whether it proves whether you have a
good argument or not at the end of the
day because the hard part is to and once
again
um
i was watching another it was it was
just basically a a youtube playlist of
debates and i don't know who these
people are exactly but jordan peterson
was one of them i actually don't know
what jordan peters is about but i just
like
how calm and poised he is right so one
of the things that he calls people out
on is when somebody insults him he goes
okay but i want you to rephrase that
question without insulting me you know
and it always stumps them it's like
you're not slick you know right he's not
slick by sitting here by basically
calling me a misogynist or or an idiot
or that i'm stupid for my ideas and he
goes cool well can you do it without
assaulting me now and then they they get
stumped it's like you're not slick here
yeah and right you know it's it's
problematic in how people
communicate with somebody right so if
you're here to have a conversation yeah
conversations get heated or whatever
what not but if you're not gonna sit
there and listen to somebody speak and
kind of hear what they say then you're
not really here for the conversation at
all it's a got you moment yeah you're
just looking for that got you moment
that you're trying to walk away with hot
i got you [ __ ] you and then walk off so
what's the whole point of this then yeah
what's the whole point of this
conversation that's what happens to a
lot of people now you see that [ __ ] on
twitter and that's why i love it when
dave chappelle says hey twitter is not
real yeah it's not bro because it's not
not everybody should not be
putting out their thoughts to the world
everybody thinks that their thoughts
need to be heard and guess what they
actually don't you're not that everybody
keeps telling you that you're the
special [ __ ] human being yeah you're
special to your friends and your close
family you have something that's very
special about you but the whole world
doesn't have to believe in that
specialness that makes you you exactly
it is not you can't sit there hoping
everybody to believe how awesome you are
you'll sit there with your [ __ ] mouth
open until it's dry as [ __ ] yeah getting
nothing that's just bird droppings in
that [ __ ] all day it's also just crazy
it's crazy dude like my my uncle
actually made a really good po like we
were talking about social media in
general and he was like i think
the way
like social media right now is like what
cigarettes were like in the 50 like the
40s 50s when they were like oh yeah
secrets are fine blah blah you know
doctors are smoking it he's like but i
think in like 50 60 years it's going to
be like social media is like our version
of cigarettes like in 60 years from now
we're gonna be like [ __ ] stay the [ __ ]
away from this or like only do a little
bit because this [ __ ] will [ __ ] you like
it mentally and i i i think it's true i
think it's so true i think that the
analogy is so he found that out when
facebook instagram and whatsapp crashed
everybody freaked the [ __ ] out yeah i
didn't even know it crashed i was in
hawaii so i didn't know it crashed i was
just chilling and then i read an article
later on when it came back up that like
instagram is back i'm like oh when did
it shut off yeah cause i don't know who
gives a [ __ ] well yeah exactly i'm not
looking at that [ __ ] 24 7 and if it
crashed for a day who the [ __ ] cares
like move on with your [ __ ] life but
that is
what your uncle says people are addicted
to that [ __ ] yeah to the point where
they freak the [ __ ] out and the funniest
thing about those articles is that when
they were talking about the facebook
employee who was a whistleblower and and
the whistleblower was basically saying
obvious [ __ ] these companies care about
money more than your safety no [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah it has always been about money
the fact that
80 of the population was surprised at
facebook a multi-billion dollar company
doesn't give a [ __ ] about your privacy
and safety blows my [ __ ] mind yeah
when we talk if i said right now to this
phone dildo dildo dildo dildo dillard
dildo on her ads instagram ads24 [ __ ]
seven if you download a website a search
engine called duckduckgo right
duckduckgo is the best search engine
that you could look for because it
doesn't have any of those bots in that
[ __ ] they block everything doctor go
when you when you search on duckduckgo
it tells you what websites are linked to
other ones for ads yeah so when you're
on facebook it'll block facebook
instagram and all this other [ __ ]
because they're all connected this is
clearly obvious [ __ ] the fact that 80 of
the population didn't understand that
blows my [ __ ] mind and just that
algorithm is so [ __ ] powerful right
like the way people get wrapped up in
the social media [ __ ] they're scrolling
swirling scrolling like the whole point
of the app is to see how long they can
get you on a [ __ ] app use it for what
it's good for use it for your
entertainment if you want to laugh you
want to post about your life but this
stuff isn't real [ __ ] life that's not
right you keep basing your life off of
[ __ ] memes 24 7. i have seen so many
kids who are so awkward because you guys
repeat memes as if they're real
conversation times like when they talk
to women this means that oh when you
talk to women make sure you talk with
confidence and they not come up to a
girl and they're two inches away from
her face hi my name is john it's like
why because you read on a [ __ ] meme
give her some space [ __ ]
like you're so busy taking advice from
[ __ ] three three sentence [ __ ]
excerpts out of a social media app that
you think these are life books those are
snippets
with the grain of [ __ ] salt that's
why you're so [ __ ] awkward that's why
you when you're on these dating apps you
have 17 office jokes because you think
that's going to get you [ __ ] right shut
the [ __ ] up and get out there and talk
to a [ __ ] human being that's my ted
talk yeah yeah you're like trying to be
relatable all the time to these people
you know it's like it's not real
conversation just have a conversation
ask people about themselves also talk
about yourself whatever and i 100 say
this too because i grew up with such
crazy social anxiety right that i kept
on looking for these shortcuts on how to
socialize with human beings and all i
had to do was just socialize go out
there and fail consistently to know oh
this is a little weird this is a little
odd yeah right that's just trial and
error yeah you're trying to dig all the
time yeah that's how it works yeah or
somebody who unzips their pets i don't
have to suck that dick yeah you know i
could just be like not today sir walk
off boundaries
that's your lying
homies for life dude all day
don't you shame me for my friend all
right i didn't steal his [ __ ] bunions
dude
we were looking off into the distance
eating some funyuns together i don't
know if you were eating you're right i
don't know what the [ __ ] he was eating
all right that wasn't my responsibility
my responsibility was to protect him at
all cost yeah for the funyuns
and that's it did he ever get bullied ah
i don't know i got expelled after third
grade whatever happened to him after i
don't know what happened but yeah but
you did your part hey yeah kindergarten
until third grade nobody [ __ ] with rum
deep not that's that's dope
and you you had an insatiable thirst for
[ __ ] funyuns from abundance out and i
just kept gaining weight
so much weight dude the finances will
[ __ ] get you boys i love funyuns so
when i would protect him and take all
the shots i didn't feel anything yeah
all day and he was smile and she was
just guarded by my [ __ ] you're like
dude
i absorbed it
that's right dude i'm pink and fat
without my shirt
how [ __ ] dary patrick is master roshi
i think is that the old guy yeah yeah
bro that's who i aspire to be like
honestly 100 i always like i feel like
the dopest dude in animes oh it's like a
trope of anime but the old dude that
looks really frail yeah but then like
when he takes his shirt off it's time to
get down he's like
he's like rip dude he always looks super
[ __ ] weak and you go oh my god that's
the legend from bob hey bob yeah yeah
like that's always been the dopest dude
for me in anime i've always been and
then when you see the girls you get the
nosebleeds yeah yeah yeah oh yeah you
know his thing he's always trying to
[ __ ] he's super horny
yeah all right that's you dude that's
not me horny boy i'm not your horny boy
you horny boy
you think i'm a horny boy i think you're
a horny but i don't know what you mean i
think every day you just think about sex
right when you wake up you're like where
can i stick this little [ __ ] shirt
i'll be trying to shoot me down she's
like
sucker wow she calls you a sucker a
little [ __ ] ass do you wake her up by
masturbating furiously next to her in
the bed i've only done that like four or
five times this week and no go do you
dry humper oh yeah all the time i'm like
trying to get it she's a little nasty
little snail trail on her leg you sick
[ __ ] dude my snail trails are crazy bro
okay i didn't need to hear that
legit the fact that you think it was a
snail trail could have gone all year
without knowing that [ __ ] hey comment
below if you guys got snapchats dude
check his boxer dude just glimmer of
lying just
glimmering
all the way down to his [ __ ] thigh
wow gross that's disgusting bro you're
starting to [ __ ] rumors about me that
i don't appreciate it easy why do you
think i'm a horn ball you think i'm a
[ __ ] sure hornball dude what do you
mean you think i'm a deviant oh you're a
sexual deviant for sure in what way what
proof do you want to
open up your [ __ ] phone and let's see
your google search right now
and guess what
if you deleted all the cash in the
cookies i already know you did some
weird [ __ ] where is my phone
yours [ __ ]
what are those flowers
[ __ ]
[Music]
go look at my [ __ ] browser bam bro
why is your phone so sticky bro
it's floating on my palm
oh what is this feet online
wow you're in defeat [ __ ] no [ __ ] it was
just like what you're wearing
for a client what's your thing you're
like weird something weird huh bro i
don't i'm very vanilla dog in vanilla
boy i like
like mission second and that's it right
why the [ __ ] you looking at whitney
houston all the time dude oh i
photoshopped my face on my buddy uh he
just he got a job as a bodyguard so i
photoshopped my face on whitney houston
and his face onto kevin costner and
that's real i'll show it to you right
yeah i believe it it was with john john
john just got a job high-end security
job wow that's what i did this [ __ ] is
literally just just fight [ __ ] and uh
whitney houston
yeah i'm a big fan of whitney houston
you don't masturbate with your phone you
sick [ __ ] what do you masturbate with
[ __ ] my tears do you jerk off i uh
donned a track list there's a picture of
my vaccine card
the travel hawaii what time is it in
washington state
look that up disgusting because i have
clients that i have to do different time
zones and time zones are so hard to deal
with isn't washington the same time zone
it's an hour ahead which is like
what do you mean wow it's hour ahead oh
really
huh i don't know how timezone works i
don't get it either oh [ __ ] never mind
it's not
are you [ __ ] loser let's just all be
on the same time yeah let's just be on
the same time well hurry up and watch
this [ __ ] show i'm gonna watch it
watch it dude i want to [ __ ] wear
games
though i want to watch that
[ __ ] i wish you saw it so we could talk
about it yeah but we can't talk about it
because you didn't [ __ ] watch it you
didn't watch the show
dude i didn't know what we're going to
talk about you said we're going to talk
about deontay wilder and all that [ __ ]
i know
inflammatory [ __ ] yeah bro so maybe it
was a blessing in disguise that we
[ __ ] didn't have it recorded but it
was fun and we were laughing our phone
at the end of the day i'm just here to
hang out with you guys man yeah we're
doing this recording it gets recorded
we just haven't laughed yeah that's why
i keep [ __ ] up we're talking [ __ ] i
need to have a bad time when i do this
[ __ ] i keep [ __ ] around i'm like oh
wait we're supposed to do work right now
aren't we
[ __ ] yeah we end up talking all [ __ ]
night like a bunch of [ __ ] but it's
just fun dude and that
is what friendship is you entered my
life three years ago yeah biggest
mistake ever best thing about you is i
got to be here
no it's actually crazy how like
everything has turned out like as far as
like us all hanging out and [ __ ] like
that the fact that we were in hawaii and
we saw each other for like two hours and
[ __ ] [ __ ] you duck
this guy was so happy to see me bro
[ __ ] hey tip she's a little instigated
bro
hey she likes blowing my spot like you
meet up with david and she goes hey
david you know this is how tiff talked
and she goes nick was so excited to see
i'm like yo what the [ __ ]
is she just like blowing on my spot but
i wasn't like excited to see you yeah
you're a man crushing a little bit yeah
snail trailer
yeah i got a bunch of sand on my cooter
right
i was like the [ __ ] is that glitch we
saw like two hours of the whole [ __ ]
trip wow we didn't hang much because you
should have came to the dinner i had
because it was delicious how was the
vietnamese curry it was [ __ ] hella
good i looked it up afterwards i've
never had that cracker crab curry hella
good i looked it up afterwards look
delicious dude that sounds amazing
i love curry oh actually you did a great
thing yeah we didn't do this [ __ ]
delicious we didn't go to some whack ass
[ __ ] bro gilbert you fat useless [ __ ]
yeah why don't you go on the podcast you
[ __ ] you know why people do he's so busy
i don't do podcasts oh i have to put
banana ketchup on everything bro making
plans with gilbert in hawaii so
frustrating the worst tiff was like why
does gilbert do this why is he so
difficult but he was like doing work and
[ __ ] i get it whatever all we got to do
is spar him and then piece them up a
little bit and then we'll be all great
cheeks next time i see you guys
too bad you're so [ __ ] lovable [ __ ]
yeah dude this fool's an enigma bro
every time we were walking down like we
were walking down waikiki and he was
like cracking jokes and then so many
random people like want to join in and
be like
it's hilarious and they walk by they
[ __ ] love this [ __ ] guy wherever
we go he's making friends with everybody
at the restaurant that's dope cut it out
he looks like a filipino radio host
that's why he wants to [ __ ] everybody i
think it's like he's constantly sending
out way like signals to [ __ ] see in a
relationship yeah yeah long term
fiancee
wow that's cindy
simon cindy lou cindy
the best well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast that
we did record i see all the lights yeah
you'll see it we gotta check from now on
here check in right now we gotta check i
checked that one earlier i think i think
it was on it was red it was on is that
good it was on if it wasn't on i'm gonna
make it work i'm gonna i'm gonna get an
engineer to edit this [ __ ] we're gonna
have to do adr you're gonna have to do
adr for everybody i got you don't
[ __ ] worry dude i've been doing this
for years i've never made a mistake in
my life are you gonna hire an engineer
to like do all this stuff well next year
i'm trying to
pizzazz it up because we're only doing
one a week let's go so i if it's if
something [ __ ] up it's not my fault
yeah i need somebody else to do because
i do everything myself it's so funny too
because i'll edit this stuff and then
people were writing comments they're
like do whoever edits has been calling
david out on all this [ __ ] i'm like
i write everything
i write the titles i i write the
timestamps for you
like what do you mean well because i'll
like you know say some stupid [ __ ] and
i'll put it as a time stamp and i'm like
they're like dude whoever's editing even
knows that david's like saying all this
[ __ ] i'm like i write them yeah
david knows he's saying
i write the timestamp
like what are you talking about you
[ __ ] hate her leave me alone it hurts
sorry
hey you ain't gonna get away with that
bro you're not gonna get away with that
with a little i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm so sorry you're a [ __ ]
check out nick at nick dunn he's a he's
a physical teacher if you guys need
coaching for fitness that's what it is
strength training you know getting your
weight down just hit your boy up i've
only got 36 pounds since knowing him
yeah
a pure dog meat you lost your weight by
yourself you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're a
physical teacher man
he's a physical teacher i teach pe bruh
that's right that's what it is
i got a degree in it all right watch
your [ __ ] mouth physical education
yeah
i got a real [ __ ] degree in science
bro that's right you should check it out
patrick patrick dot t-dot riley yeah you
can see him at the strip club swinging
the thing around
thursdays and sundays up until january
1st
january first only one overall
hits him with the woe see you all next
time